Estados Unidos respondió a esta medida
diciendo que la OPEP o diciendo que esta
Alianza estaba alineándose con Rusia
realmente podría tratarse de una
decisión política
bueno
hablar del petróleo y decir que no es
político es ser bastante
Ingenio Pero obviamente tiene este
componente pero tiene también el
componente de la OPEP Close de tratar de
defender los precios de Cara a lo que
ellos ven como una potenciación
potencial recesión como tu bien
apuntastes es una mensaje más que todo
nominal porque como tú bien dijistes No
están produciendo lo que deberían
producir y de hecho al decir que van a
recortar dos millones versos las cuotas
de agosto lo que están es sincerando la
incapacidad del grupo en este momento de
producir esos volúmenes
ahora cuál es el impacto que esta medida
puede tener por ejemplo para Estados
Unidos y sobre todo para yo bailén justo
un mes de las elecciones de medio
término
eso también Es una excelente pregunta
los precios del petróleo ya venían
subiendo el mercado había factorizado el
hecho de que este recorte iba a ocurrir
así si fuera nominal
Porque además
la OPEP los que está diciendo es yo
controlo el mercado de petróleo ya que
el otro mayor productor que es los
Estados Unidos no está respondiendo
debido a razones de política interna en
primer lugar y de razones
financieras en segundo lugar eso
Obviamente que va a afectar los precios
de la gasolina y los precios de la
gasolina en el sistema electoral
norteamericano que es el que viene ahora
en noviembre tiene un efecto quizás
exagerado pero lo tienen entonces para
la administración bailen es un golpe
señor Pacheco ya lo decía usted afecta
el precio de la gasolina de los
estadounidenses pero Cómo afecta esto el
bolsillo de la población en general esto
teniendo en cuenta la situación
energética que está afectando
principalmente a Europa y que se deriva
de la guerra en Ucrania y las tensiones
con Rusia
Sí bueno deriva de la atención es con
Rusia pero también deriva de políticas
asociadas a desincentivar inversiones En
el mercado fósiles pero para responder
tu pregunta directamente
es el precio de los combustibles tiene
un impacto directo en casi toda la
economía porque el transporte se ve
afectado la generación de la
electricidad se ve afectada el precio
del gas que también va en paralelo al
del petróleo por razones similares
también afecta toda la economía Entonces
al final del día el precio de la energía
en una sociedad moderna se ve reflejado
en lo que el consumidor paga en cada uno
y todos estos productos